are a cause of my cancer? How does that exactly happen? I think you're asking
how do toxins cause cancer? Well, remember, anything that gets inside of a cell has
the ability to damage cellular components. It can damage your mitochondria, it can
damage your lysosomes, it can damage any of your organelles can be damaged due to
toxins or anything that gets inside of a cell. If it damages the nucleus and
causes it to go into rapid replication, it is a cause of cancer. So what can be
a cause of cancer? You know, you hear read about things or used to back in the 80s and
90s all the time. That barbecue eat food is a cause of cancer. This is a cause of
cancer. This is a cause of cancer. This chemical is a cause of cancer. If you go, oh my gosh, I can't do anything.
The truth is anything that you don't detoxify anything that you absorb that is
circulating in your blood and you don't detoxify is going to be pushed to extra
cellular spaces and then eventually can be put in two cells. If anything that gets
inside of a cell has the potential of being a cause of cancer. Now, not everything gets inside
your cells, but anything that does get inside a cell has the potential of causing cancer.
It's always something that gets inside of a cell. Could it be a bacteria? Yes. Could it be a virus?
Yes. Could it be a toxin? Yes. So bacteria and viruses are labeled biotoxins,
they're living organisms and inert things are labeled toxins. So it could be a biotoxin
or a toxin that gets inside of the cell. Damage is a nucleus that causes it to go into rapid
replication. That's what happens. The truth is you can live to a hundred and twenty years old,
never get cancer. We dissect your body and we see lots of cells that have toxins in them. It doesn't
mean it's going to. It means it can. It has the ability to damage your nucleus and then cause cancer.
Now the truth is that everybody's getting cancer all the time, but you have healthy tumor
suppressor genes, your tumor suppressor system kicks in, kills that cancer before it's a hundred
cells large. It can't be seen on a CT scan MRI or PET scan until it's three million cells large.
Oh, that's large. It's been going on for a long time. Usually a cancer doesn't get identified,
diagnosed as a cancer until it's been growing for years. Now there has been evidence of what's
called turbo cancers since the recent jam and that is because the spike proteins can be a major
cause of cancer and it causes cancer to grow quite quickly. That's what's been labeled as a
turbo cancer. We need somebody who gets diagnosed and they pass away within three months even before
treatment can start because it's growing so quickly. So the rate of cancer of that cellular replication
is different with different cancers. It's different with different people. The purpose that you want to
develop in the diagnosis of cancer is that you slow the rate of replication. Everybody wants their
cancer to go away. They want it to disappear. That's not always possible. You want it to stop growing.
You want it to stop replicating. That's really what you have to do. If it stops replicating,
then it's technically really not a cancer. Yeah, but the mass is still here. I know, but it's not
replicating anymore so it's just a tumor now. So the bulky that tumor might be a good thing to do
might be a bad thing to do. You don't want to wake it up so it depends on where it is if it's affecting
other orgates as well.